aux clayes-sous-bois la houlette de luxe
one nation sort peu à peu de terre la
date d'ouverture vient d'être annoncée
ce sera le 20 novembre le concept
rassembler des marques de luxe qui
proposeront leurs collections de l'année
précédente à prix cassés jusqu'à 70% de
réduction pendant les soldes
cent douze marques se partageront les
vingt-quatre mille mètres carrés de
surfaces commerciales et cela représente
évidemment pour le département des
créations d'emplois aujourd'hui on a
identifié un besoin d'environ 800 postes
constitué de responsables de boutiques
d'adjoints et de conseillers de vente
aujourd'hui nous avons mis en place une
cvthèque sur le site advantail et
bientôt sur le site web des jeunes sur
lequel donc les candidats sont à même de
déposer à la fois leur cv et leur
candidature un partenariat a également
été lancé avec la mairie pôle emploi est
un organisme de formation un complexe de
mode et de luxe qui devrait rapporter
selon les développeurs 270 millions de
chiffre d'affaires d'ici cinq ans et
pour assurer une certaine affluence des
navettes achemineront les potentiels
acheteurs en provenance de paris ou à
nice on compte également sur les 20
millions de visiteurs annuels de la zone
commerciale de grand plaisir pour les
initiateurs du projet tout est lancée
alors leurs concurrents directs car et
privés ouest à montigny ne leur fait pas
peur et évidemment on a beaucoup de
respect pour pour hammerson beaucoup de
respect pour la vigne de montigny il
nous semble on le dit depuis depuis
quelques temps que
les fondamentaux nous pour le magasin de
vraiment orienté mode et luxe ne sont
pas ne sont pas présents malheureusement
sur sky ouest avec 107 millions d'euros
investis dans ce projet toute
concurrence serait effectivement mal
venu pour rappel le projet carré privé
ouest devrait compter 80 boutiques